welcome to this video playing Grand
Master golden wood yeah this is some
great master I'm yeah come on rust him
off right
I wish them off yeah like Sumner was to
offer okay very good
GM in his 2500 um okay cut
he's playing if I see nobody doing that
it's known a different player but okay
and splits
okay I'm gonna one of the mainline mean
light mean lively he's taking a sweet
time to put this out it's a really good
let's player so I'm a bit surprised that
he's that low rated is very often like a
2500 or 600 even in in five minute and
the poor analysis II okay I'm going for
my usual
regrouping the author Rubinstein
regrouping yeah I don't even mind total
closing of the queenside
the rubenstein regrouping that I'm
referring to as you will witness soon
it's putting the nights over to to to g7
+ f7 just wait for a moment here we go
you probably have seen dozens in earlier
games I've played played this really a
number of times
hmm I'm a bit surprised that he's
changed on before and yeah not like it's
bad for white but if white is playing
with c4 he normally normally closes the
whole structure down
yeah I don't really think that I have
any problems here this should be fairly
okay okay queen bee seven to trade
everything off okay so the best that you
can do is to get the rook on a seven ham
I just need to see that I'm coordinated
well long term this is not a bad
structure because of their five break I
can even play this breaking now but I'm
worried about Luke a seven I want to
exchange rooks if possible okay let me
see what I can do about this so what how
can I get get the rooks exchanged maybe
came to e8 group to be 8 and then Bishop
d8 and so on getting this regrouping on
the way yeah one possible idea is f4 or
the piece acro files on beef one first
and foremost I need to get rid of this
rook yeah okay here I can take or I can
yeah I think I should take I can take or
I can just just keep the position as it
is
okay
taking only three are not not sure okay
I wanted to do this anyway getting
Bishop b6 to get the rook out of this
out of my camp oh I didn't see that
coming
I know this is really really
uncomfortable
this happens if you only think about
strategy and maneuvers and don't
calculate any move wow that's not good I
mean and totally unnecessary and this
structure was just totally okay for like
now I have no move yet I mean for the
king he takes e5 n t7 I'm losing a piece
then no so really no way no amazing
really amazing so what about this should
be six takes Bishop e6 you can take
these seven that's really really
annoying and night h5 is just just
catastrophic structure cannot do that
yeah I need to play that I really see
nothing else if he moves the rook back
I'm okay and now he just has this gotten
this trade and and I guess stuff like a
five now yeah or just this I mean the
only hope is possible counter play
against the b3 pawn but I have a dead
bishop on b6 bad I just need to look at
just need to prevent this Bishop h6
business and I'm totally fine
I can still put up some resistance but
of course white should win problem is of
course my really really bad bishop yeah
no no this this piece gets get some life
at least it's not really helping me that
much but I don't know it should serve
one position
it's not clear what is what you should
do it now not so easy it moves the night
I have Bishop's III and it's not so easy
the ship see ya here maybe advance just
not sure if I have come to play now I
mean definite counter play with rugae
one
huh yeah that's not clear not at least I
don't see at the moment how he wins
no time check-check
I know this was this wasn't a good idea
yeah [ __ ] him I can I can resign that ya
frustrating frustrating really it was it
was still a bit tricky but the whole
problem is that in this position there
is really nothing going on I mean I'm
just okay here it is a bit passive but
there's absolutely no problem you know I
can do whatever I just need to I just
need to make sure that I'm not running
into the stupid Bishop h6 for example
here I can I can just do something else
I mean let's say I play here just to to
show the point I do this and what is y
doing yeah not much really can do
whatever King f2 you know I go here and
he is on the retreat mode and at the end
I will trade off the rook and after that
the game is basically over in terms of
playing for any edge for white I just
put a knight on e5 and I'm okay it's
it's nothing great but it's just a
position that that simply holds him and
I I didn't really he I didn't see he
could have played it earlier but this is
just terrible now I didn't really think
in terms of concrete moves here I have
no move I mean something like that as
this is totally low like we consider
this uneven Bishop t1 and I'm sure I'm
busted yeah the way it it it was played
I mean white should certainly win
somehow but it is it was still a bit a
bit tricky in a way yeah well him no
need really to analyze that maybe there
was some improvements but the point is I
shouldn't really come to this position
okay thanks for watching